this week's 48 hours investigates how a
determined mother was able to find her
daughter's body
after 15 years without answers in 2005
christy wilson disappeared from a
northern california casino
last seen with mario garcia a man later
convicted of her murder
garcia never revealed where he left her
as erin moriarty reports
with the help of two investigators
wilson's mother finally
got her answer
last summer investigators nuno tavares
and don murchison
who worked for the district attorney in
placer county california
got a tip that led them to the former
home of a convicted killer
named mario garcia the one thing mario
is is consistent
he's a consistent narcissistic
manipulator and nuno says garcia
has been trying to manipulate detectives
since he was found guilty of killing
christy wilson a young woman he met in a
casino back in 2005.
the 27 year old was last seen leaving
that night with garcia
but he denied having anything to do with
her disappearance
how could she simply disappear after she
was with you
i don't have answers for that convinced
garcia was lying
christie's mother debbie boyd went
public i want my daughter back
and i want her back now years passed and
in 2018
garcia let debbie know he wanted to be
released early from his 59-year prison
sentence
and she considered negotiating with him
i was sitting there
thinking what on earth are you doing
debbie get a grip
this would be such
a disgrace he will not use my daughter's
body as a bargaining chip
no one ever guessed that garcia's own
family would play a role
in finding chrissy's remains in 2019
the investigators asked garcia's eldest
son chris
a teenager in 2005 about his father's
movements in the days
after christy went missing he saw his
dad working
on a tractor working kind of frantically
and
had kind of a crazed look in his eyes as
he was working around the property
nuno said chris never put two and two
together
but detectives did and last summer
they returned to the killer's former
property
we started pulling back about 25 feet
pulling just a couple of inches at a
time
went about 18 feet wide and we stopped
everything we froze everything
we found christy this is a day that we
had hoped for
my prayers have been answered we can now
move forward without the torment of the
past 15 years
erin moriarty joins us now uh erin
beyond closure which is a powerful
motivator
why did christy's family work so hard
her mother in particular to find her
remains
well debbie boyd told us that every
single night for 15 years she would go
to bed
saying where did he put her where did he
put her i mean he wanted to bury her
but there was also a legal reason
remember this was a no
body prosecution there wasn't a lot of
evidence against mario garcia and he was
filing appeal after appeal
if one of those appeals was heard and
any evidence thrown out
he could have walked and then she never
would have found out so there was real
pressure to find out where christy
wilson was so you met mario
garcia the the convicted killer in this
case what struck you most about him
well tony i'll tell you he was good he
had well crafted answers for most
everything he was so credible that i
have to be
honest i worried and so did my producer
again a no-body prosecution that they
had the right guy
but now this morning as i sit here i
know that he was just an
extremely good liar wow
aaron moriarty thank you very much
looking forward to that report you can
watch the full report
the search for christy wilson on 48
hours tomorrow night
at 10 9 central right here on cbs